welcome to matt's code house today
don't worry it's not a programming
tutorial it's the nine
best gifts it's your program or friend
or
family member or whoever just the nine
gifts that i would like to get as a
programmer that's basically what this
actually is well
let's dive into it but first let's just
take a look at some recent comments and
answer a few things because
why not i'd like to listen to you guys
we got uh highway jesus spitting
knowledge
uh thank you i guess i like it
take it and uh okay that was on the
joshua flute video i did like
two years ago or something and uh on the
cmake tutorials this is a nice tutorial
thank you for making it you're welcome
coo hi sian chen said that right
and we got hey matt have you considered
directx 11 tutorial series ah
glad you asked and it looks like people
have responded i put up a
oh it looks like most people would
rather see
c plus plus graphic tutorials on opengl
right now and second is vulcan and third
is directx
and then cross platform libraries to do
all three actually beat out directx but
i don't know there's some
little discrepancy between these three
because if you don't want opengl
you probably want vulcan or directx so
you can almost combine these
and say it's like a 40
you know if it's opengl or something
else you know
or something like that all right well
let's get into some
some some programmer gifts
and yes i will be continuing my opengl
video sorry i keep interrupting my gifts
don't worry i just gotta i just gotta i
got a red shirt
well the first thing you should consider
getting your programmer friend is a
sweet sweet keyboard you know i've got
this
logitech pro link down below i guess it
apparently messes up the color
on my green screen oh no not again don't
worry guys i figured out how to fix this
chroma key okay actually what i need to
do is i need to go to my camera settings
and make it not auto adjust because the
auto adjust keeps changing the coloring
anytime i get something with other
variants on the screen
uh ai it's not very good at being ai
okay well anyway all i gotta do is go to
select
color bring the similarity down select
color
screen color let's do this here we go i
don't know i know you guys can't see
this bring the similarity back
up not too much though okay this is
creepy
now this is just i'm invisible man i'm
invisible
i'm coming back fading back into reality
yeah
and also here's another one if you don't
want to get the expensive 120 dollar
logitech pro one which i really like who
wouldn't want to try this thing out just
look at this keyboard
and it's under 50 bucks i have no idea
if it's good but it actually gets pretty
good reviews 120 ratings and four and a
half stars is pretty good
and it's under 50 bucks i want to try
this thing out this thing just looks
sweet so what programmer would want to
get this if nothing else
you got an extra sweet keyboard well
that's it that's the
number nine so what about number eight i
guess we're going in reverse order
here we're gonna have to build up to
number one although these aren't in any
particular order actually the ones i
thought of first i'm telling you first
so these are probably actually the
better ones but uh yeah okay let's move
on to the next one what else would a
programmer
or a coder or someone that just loves
computers in general might like a lot of
these
a standing desk that comes in a bunch of
different sizes
i purchased one of these recently and
i'll let you i'll let you guys know how
it goes
i will let you know but you get in
different sizes the the smallest one's
actually not
too bad it's pretty reasonable so yeah i
think every programmer needs one of
these you end up sitting a lot
and with one of these you can just use
these little buttons over here
over here it's hard okay and raise it
any time you want
that way you can stand up for a while
and do your coding thing i had one of
these on my last job and it was awesome
i think it's required
so that's why i got one because i
haven't had one at home pretty much ever
and i think it's
it's due time and here's just another
version of a more
i don't know plain looking one i guess
they're both pretty plain really
yeah a great gift i think it's if you
know someone that doesn't have one that
uses the computer all the time
you pretty much got to get them one of
these it's required now click the link
buy it maybe it feels like a link and
the next obvious thing is a
head chair a sweet chair you got to get
one with the high back and you got to
get one with a leg rest because
this is just like the pinnacle of
computer chairs so if you know someone
that has crappy chair
they would absolutely love something
like this link also down below this is
number seven
all right let's move on to number six
maybe you just have no idea what to get
them
you never know what makes them happy get
them a gift card for the thing
there you go let them decide make it
easy
this is a total cop-out because uh who
wouldn't want an amazon gift card
am i right yeah confirmed and
sorry for all the background
sorry for the background clicking yeah
you're adorable
you excited about christmas yeah all
right
[Music]
you're in the camera you're just behind
me
all right let's go on to the next gift
all right number five you can't go wrong
with a good tech book there are so many
good tech books that i wish
i had so i'm just going to show you the
ones that i would
absolutely love to get because i've
always wanted them but i never got them
all right let's start looking here
this one a tour of c
plus plus it's only 23 bucks for the
paperback it's by
john strewstrom the creator of c plus
plus and i've heard this is one of the
best ways to learn but i've never
actually had the book
i'm sure any c plus coder that doesn't
love it you should do your own research
make sure they don't already have the
book all right
because if they have the book then
they're going to be a little
disappointed to get a second copy
so maybe take a look at their bookshelf
or something or say hey can i check out
your cool programming
books because i'm suddenly interested in
programming even though i never haven't
been before
sorry before christmas the annotated
touring
this book is all about well you can see
what it's about touring
a guide a guided tour
through alan turing's historic paper on
computability
and the turing machine great for any
researcher
let's look at more books as you can see
i love books i got a bunch of them here
large scale c plus plus software design
yes please
look me up all right what else what
other cool books
coding game coding complete fourth
edition i only actually recommend this
one because the other one
is unavailable and that is well okay not
this one but this one's awesome too
uh common list studies error
eridums like i say of artificial
intelligence programming by peter
norvig this is a legendary book this is
like the one everyone online tells you
to read if you
want to know anything about ai or want
to really learn it i haven't got this
one this is one i would also love
there's one i missed let me see if i can
find it this one
the game engine black book doom first
edition this is actually relatively hard
to find at this point
it's kind of an obscure book but anyways
links down below
to all of these i'm sure if you know a
programmer especially c plus plus coder
i can't really speak
javascript html guys usually they're not
into the same stuff i'm into
just saying just throwing that out there
this is more for like
game programmers all right
and i got another cop out in case you're
really really cheap so
at number i think this is number four
yeah number four
the next one just offer some kind words
of encouragement all right can you do
that
that would be the thing as you know
looking at all this difficult code all
the time
things get tricky you gotta prepare a
video in a couple days
speaking of i haven't mentioned i'll
just throw this in the middle new videos
every tuesday
and friday that's the new schedule two
days a week tuesday and friday will be a
new video
so please hit the hit the sub button got
lots of uh
coding videos you can go see my backlog
to get an idea of the stuff i make but
i'm kind of trying out a new style for
this upcoming year of this two day a
week thing and that gives me a lot of
time to think about topics and process
things and actually make a bit of a
script which is not something i've
always done in the past
all right kind words of encouragement if
you can't afford to get your
cool coder friend anything just send
them a message
to let them know you're thinking about
them and that you have faith in their
coding ability i guess
i just got this random code window up
all right let's go on to the next one
but that's a free one
you can always just reach out to someone
and say some things that makes them feel
better that's a general lesson for the
world
these days be kind and rewind your old
video tapes if you get that
you've rented a tape before all right
and
the next one this one this one is just
another thing that actually i just want
don't add me yes i want this satchel bag
just look like
look at it looks like it came straight
out of d and d well you got in there you
got some candle wax
spell components laptop i don't know
anyway
i just think this thing looks sweet and
they're actually not that expensive
there's a bunch of different versions on
amazon i'll link to this one because
this one is my favorite just look at
this thing how could you not
love this thing i would love to get this
as a gift you know
so i assume other people would too yeah
that's number three all right don't
worry we got two more
oh that's coding window all right this
one's this one's sort of interesting but
i've been looking at this site hold on a
second
this site right here ec part picker this
site
is awesome you can just build pcs but uh
right on their front page right now they
have an entry
level intel gaming build and you can
purchase all the parts for 580. so
that's not bad for a computer especially
a gaming computer that can run
any about anything right now
and it's a good foot in the door or if
you have a coder friend that's using
crappy computers
you just go on here get you a build and
send them all the parts and be like have
fun my computer buddy who loves messing
with computer parts
had a bit of extra cash and i love you
very much so i'm going to send you some
extra
computers because as a coder you always
need extra computers you might build
something on one computer but want to
test it on different stuff just to make
sure it actually
is working the way you think it's
working so it never hurts to have an
extra computer of course there's always
laptops and stuff too but i think you
can't go wrong with a gaming build if
someone doesn't have one everyone needs
one in this day and age you miss out on
so much cool stuff without one so that
would make an awesome
gift and this site would make you uh
it would help you pick parts that are
actually compatible that you know are
useful i've linked to
most of this entry level gaming build
down below
so i don't know it's a consideration
it's a consideration
but always check with them first make
sure you're not getting them a dud or
just get them that gift card if you're
really really not sure what they want
you can always go with the gift card
okay the last one this is another easy
one
this is this is just required all coders
need this there's
really no question a hooded
sweatshirt a hoodie you gotta have
hoodies i wish i had one right now to
pull up but i got this
sweet festive red sweater like button if
you like it but yeah look at all these
they're
they're not that expensive for a
standard hoodie and really all you need
is the hood it's all about the hood you
got to have the hood going on sometimes
listening to that the sweet beats and
puts you in a zone there's something
about the hood
blocking out the peripheral vision
that's what it is it's all about the
peripheral vision
and uh the focus zone i think i don't
know i'm just making that up but what do
you guys think
all right that's it that's everything
that's the whole list of items
that every coder
would love to get pretty much so if
you're not sure what to get
for christmas consider this list
and if you're not sure who to buy for
well
i just gave you a perfect list of things
that i would like guess
i'm kidding i'm kidding don't do that
geez
all right well i will see you guys in
the next episode on
you know friday unless there's some you
know i'll
i'll always make a community post or at
least do my best to
if i for some reason can't make one of
those dates but i will uh
sure plan on it that's the plan that's
what i've been practicing
all right special thanks to all my
patrons this tear
and i'll see you guys in the next one
happy holidays
take care of yourselves out there don't
catch the thing
and peace out
more tutorials and stuff soon oh man i
just wrecked my green screen
it was a perfect time to end goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
you